et on reçoit maintenant un agitateur
d'idées numérique ça vous fait rire je
me sens bien mais c'est comme ça vous
vous présenter en tout cas j'aime gens
me présent à pain vous êtes le fondateur
de l'association broadband 78 c'était
une saison qui a été créée en mars
dernier avec vous on va parler aux
fibres optiques pour les entreprises
pour les particuliers il ya un budget
qui a été assez important qui a été voté
au conseil général des yvelines
l'agglomération saint quentinois soit
brisée également le développement de la
fibre optique alors en principe d'ici
2020 tout le département devrait être
doté de fibre optique mais pour vous ça
va pas assez vite et c'est un peu le but
de la création d'autres instances à va
pas assez vite pour moi mais aussi pour
tout un tas de gens dans les yvelines
qui commence à râler parce qu'ils l'ont
pas ils n'ont pas de débit pour faire
leur business 2006 sont des entreprises
voudraient même des particuliers il
faudrait tout de suite avoir du très
haut débit à des prix les prix de 1 des
prix de grande consommation
l'association a été créée en mars elle
regroupe qui est qu'est ce que vous
pouvez faire vous en tant qu'association
et bien on peut faire le peuple peut
faire beaucoup de choses vous savez il
n'ya pas que les élus donc on a beaucoup
de chance d'avoir les élus qu'on a eus
parce qu'ils ont décidé de filmer tout
le département notre association
regroupe les membres fondateurs on était
dix sept vous avez un médecin un
expert-comptable trois retraités quatre
ou cinq entreprises dites les startups
parce qu'il y en a beaucoup dans le
département est donc l'objectif que l'on
s'est fixé il y en a 3 le premier cdd
les élus ou de les booster qui a des
élus qui comprennent pas très bien à
quoi tout ça peut servir
oui oui tout à fait mais avec internet
vous savez ces trucs faciles
deuxième chose c'est de faire monter
l'appétence du numérique pour toute la
population donc on est en train de
réfléchir pour mettre sur pied tout un
tas de choses et troisièmement c'est de
créer des entreprises dans département
se basant sur les réseaux optiques son
président eric spécia les entreprises ou
si vous créez beaucoup d'entreprises
numériques vous aurez créé des
entreprises qui sont pas numérique dans
le dans les services de laverie de
restaurants à l'émeute vous pouvez rien
faire pour accélérer le développement de
la fibre optique c'est joli vin assez
dans les questions de finances et qui
sont juridiques le développement de la
fibre optique le problème alors la
commune temps vous me donnez là je vous
donne 10 minutes
je vois qu'en france et ancien mal très
mal pris nos grands-parents ont financé
le réseau électrique ça s'est très bien
passé par un fonds de péréquation nos
pères ont financé le réseau téléphonique
ça s'est très bien passé avec des
emprunts d'état et aujourd'hui nous
c'est très compliqué pour mettre en
place la fib il ya des tas de lobby dans
tous les sens les élus ceux ci les élus
cela le problème c'est les responsables
sont les élus puisque c'est eux qui
questions qui les conduisent ces
listings ses petits patients c'est
l'époque mais qui peuvent régler le
problème juridique à ce que dit donc la
seule du très haut débit messieurs les
élus qu'est ce que vous faites alors les
élus qu'est-ce qu'ils font bâiller sur
le tourne vers français verra orange les
autres et orange dit ben nous on n'a pas
assez de sous pour faire ça tout ça donc
il faut mettre en place il faudrait
mettre en place un fonds de péréquation
le font pas le temps qui était créée par
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat mais
qui n'est pas abonder aujourd'hui pour
tout un tas de raisons donc nous notre
association nos élus à nous en sommes du
département nous aujourd'hui qu'en cinq
ans ça serait terminée donc j'ai pas de
1027 2019 ils nous ont dit puisqu'on a
reçu deux conseillers généraux dans
notre association qui sont venus nous
expliquer très simplement où on en était
ils nous ont dit que les travaux
allaient démarrer en 2014 qu'on a des
fibres est aussi tous les villages des
il n ya pas que les villes et ça
représente quand même beaucoup beaucoup
de monde et que en 2019 toutes les
terminer
16e d'avancé vous allez nous expliquer
les bienfaits de la fibre optique pour
les particuliers parce que 2,7 certaines
personnes ne savent pas à quoi ça peut
ça peut servir concrètement dans la vie
au quotidien mais d'abord je vous
propose d'aller à la rencontre des saint
quentinois et nous leur avons demandé
s'ils étaient déjà aujourd'hui la en
2013 on est mis en 2019 en 2020 en 2013
s'il était content ce 3 juillet 2013 de
leurs internet on écoute les réponses
j'habite à plaisir et même le sol et non
j'ai pas un débit suffisant ma connexion
quand je regarde des vidéos youtube
pendant des heures 18h20 minuit on va
dire bah ça sa coupe bonera pitot
j'avais un voisin le bretonneux on a été
pilote pour la connexion de la fibre
optique la fibre optique est arrivé
jusqu'au garage mais malheureusement il
n'y a pas un opérateur en face pour nous
offrir quelque chose de convenable jeu
mais assez rapide ya toujours beaucoup
de problèmes mais c'est normal parce que
je pense que les technologies
sont en contradiction entre ce qu'on
nous vend et puisqu'on fait par exemple
on nous vend un débit théorique totale
et en fait on fait du partage de débit
entre plusieurs clients donc les clients
n'ont pas le débit maximum tout le temps
oui je trouve que c'est bien et c'est
suffisant ça marche pas si mal de fois g
un peu comme les opérateurs c'est pas
bien comme une flèche et paie très cher
on n'a pas très bonne connexion internet
trouve ça va pas si vite pour les
smartphones comme la halle et je
voudrais réagir quand même sur ce qu'a
dit une cette dame de
voisins-le-bretonneux qui dit bah on m'a
installé la fibre optique jusqu'à dans
mon garage et après j'ai pas le
l'opérateur pour pour brancher tout ça
chez moi ben oui y'a beaucoup de jeu
donc ça c'est quand même un chèque à
rambouillet par exemple vous avez une
zone industrielle où on a deux de nos
membres qui sont là ils ont la fibre qui
sort devant chez eux ils ont demandé
pour l'avoir dans leur bureau et les
opérateurs ont dit que ça coûtait sur
1000 euros alors ça sert à quoi la fibre
optique d'abord on enlève le fils de
cuivre pourquoi pas parce que les débits
permis dans le fil de cuivre sont quand
même assez ridicule et en plus ils sont
ils sont pas symétriques et deuxièmement
ils sont une occasion particulière dans
l'application au quotidien et bien le
pour la fibre avec la claque bien vous
allez créer ou vous allez avoir de
nouveaux types d'applications comme par
exemple des centre de télémédecine
visiophonie qhd par exemple la crêpière
et puis il y aura plus de médecins dans
deux ans on fait quoi donc la vision
qu'on a là médicaux conférence pas vrai
il se dit déjà je vous signale le thème
l'hôpital pompidou à paris a déjà une
plate forme exacte animé avec les
maisons de retraite ensuite vous aurez
dans l'éducation avec des applicatifs
nouveau la visiophonie la visiophonie va
être là comme disent les spécialistes la
killer app l'application qui va faire
que les gens vont vouloir la voir
pouvait faire de la visiophonie
aujourd'hui avec skype etc mais avec du
débit vous pouvez faire beaucoup
beaucoup mieux donc on pourra faire
mieux on espère donc avant 1020 2019 on
espère on espère en tout cas est en tout
cas votre association est là pour faire
du lobbying veut dire ça comme ça donc
j'ai des gens veulent nous rejoindre un
problème justement et vous avez une
réunion de travail la prochaine aura
lieu le 5 juillet au vendredi à 9 le
château pour ceux qui s'intéressent à la
question et plus vous à fillon breux ça
si vous êtes fort ça sera streamé
longtemps elle c'est à dire que les gens
pourront regarder comme cette mission et
oui voilà effectivement front est
streamé m'exprimer aussi voilà donc
réunion le 5 juillet à neauphle le
château et classe a sombrement grande
bande à 60,18 si vous vous intéressez à
la question du très haut débit de la
fibre optique et voulait que ça
s'accélère un petit peu je connais tu es
vous merci beaucoup